hey guys Pete here this is gonna be my
mr. robot season 3 episode 6 recap and
review I haven't really looked at
anything about the show yet and I'm
gonna be honest that there was a point I
thought it was a great episode but there
was a point during the middle of it
where I was like wondering what the hell
was going on like I liked all the
character tension and I liked all the
way that they were all going towards
their goal but everybody had different
things that they were trying to
accomplish but something felt off about
it and I was starting to worry but in
the end it turned out to be really cool
the ending the ending wrap things up in
a way that it all made sense to me and
I've left the room after watching
thinking that man that was pretty cool
though the episode starts off with the
flashback and we see Angela as a child -
strange gathering where her mother knows
she's going to die so she's throwing a
party a farewell party for herself there
was a bit of strange foreshadowing in
this like there was a sort of it almost
made you think that they were trying to
make us wonder if that she has a mr.
robot of her own because of what her
mother said to her also they of course
there was - back to the future part tune
that was lying but I think the real
takeaway here was Edward Alderson asked
her to look out for Elliot and give him
a push when he needed one and then we
cut back to present time where we see
them in that confrontation from the end
of last episode we see that these two
childhood friends that are connected
forever with a bond that's about losing
both of their parents to this
corporation they both tried to write
that in their own ways we can see at
this point in time they are
diametrically opposed neither one of
them can see the big picture Elliot just
wants to stop people from losing their
lives Angela just wants justice and it
ends in them in uncertain territory to
say the least he knows that she had
manipulated his other side his mr. robot
side he finds out that she's been in
contact with white rose which is
distressing for him and we see why later
but she's a true believer at this point
and he knows
but there's bigger things that he has to
deal with and he heads across town to
try to stop the explosion himself in
that transition from building 1 to
building 2 he tips off Darlene about
Tyrells location at the red wheelbarrow
this gets passed on to DOM and her
partner norm they try to take it to
Santiago but of course Santiago doesn't
want to do anything because he works for
the dark army and you know it stands out
at this point that DOM is bright she's
exceptionally bright she's shown herself
to be that by the end of this episode
she must have serious concerns about
Santiago's loyalties there's no way that
she could miss that it's pretty clear
that every time she wants to make an
attack towards them something that will
benefit their investigation against the
dark army he gets in the way eventually
Dom can't stand to sit at her desk and
let it go she gets a call from Darlene
and that kind of sets her off and her
and norm go to surveil the place
themselves I go right to the red
wheelbarrow and from that point on the
episode sort of switches back and forth
between Elliot and Dom Dom really
doesn't even know about the tight
timeframe that she's dealing with here
she just wants to find Tyrell and is
afraid that he'll flee but Elliott's up
against a very serious timeline because
he knows that the building's gonna come
down and as he's arriving he realizes
his bomb threat deal didn't work at all
they're putting the people back inside
the building so he have them both going
after their goal and it lines up pretty
good the intensity lines up pretty good
at the same time because Dom went to her
superior Santiago and he contacted
Irving Tyrell is pretty much screwed
he's expecting that this attacks gonna
go off and he's gonna get whisked away
to Kiev with Johanna and Irving in his
silence lets him know that that's not
going to happen he hands them some
instructions that we never find out
what's actually inside those and he ends
up a well he tells him to burn him after
he reads them and in the process of
doing that that gets Dom inside because
of the smoke from the fire
so Tyrells on the run and Elliot is
starting to glitch with mr. robot taking
minutes and seconds
anything he can from him to stop him
from the building exploding and well I
thought this was interesting at first it
started to drag on me a little bit and
that's the part I was saying where I
wasn't sure I felt about the episode in
retrospect like I said it's pretty
brilliant because it built up this idea
in my head at the time of why is this
even happening we know Elliot's not
going to get blown up inside the
building so why are they dragging this
out so long so yeah you know that was my
initial take at the time I did love the
part whenever they were going down the
hall and he was literally bashing
himself off of things though I mean that
was funny and then of course it was it
was great when they finally started to
talk on notepad to each other what's
cool about it though is that no one
actually knows what's going down we see
White Rose and price at mar-a-lago which
was a it was a funny bit it was a little
bit overdone I think I think just the
mar-a-lago napkin and the mention of the
decor would have been enough to make
that funny I think they took it a little
bit too far and kind of made it like
stick at a point but anyways it was good
I'm glad they put it in there
those two are meeting we have no idea
what's in their heads but we think that
White Rose is trying to blow up this
building just to piss off price after
price get got him his vote for the Congo
turns out Angela believes Irving that
they're gonna evacuate the building
that's not happening Elliot believes
that they're gonna blow up the building
and then his alter mr. robot believes
that they need to blow up the building
so there's all this tension and all this
insanity and then you have Darlene
showing up at Angela's place but no one
out of anybody that I just mentioned
actually knows what's going down so that
was very that was very cool and I
definitely give them credit for laying
it out like that because we see what
happens mr. robot finds out that the
documents aren't actually there as a
team him and Elliot get into the room
and saved that building
it feels like a season finale moment of
a cheesy TV show where everybody you
know everything is set
we know it's episode six so it's not the
season finale you're wondering what's
going on
even Elliot's little talk about what
will mr. robot do doesn't have that much
real impact until after what he sees
when he walks down the street in the
same with Darlene and Angela when
they're talking you're like what the
hell you know what I mean like she's not
gonna turn Angela in Angela doesn't
isn't gonna turn so there's all this
cool stuff going on and then Angela and
Darlene both get alerts on their phone
and I didn't even know what that was
like when we were watching it the first
time I was clueless as to what that
indicated I was like is they trying to
make it out like I don't know I had no
idea I was just like what are these what
why did they stop and look at their
phones and when Elliot goes outside this
music says FEM pretty consistent with
the action genre and the end of a high
tense car chase or something like that
you know it goes silent as Elliot sees
the TV and sees what the real deal was
and who's really in charge and that is
whiterose so it was another good episode
it really was like it took me on a
journey
I mean Tyrell is in custody I really
know how that's gonna play out I don't
know if he was supposed to do that or if
I mean we don't know we don't have any
idea what was inside that letter so I'll
be interested to see what you guys think
about that
angela is kind as a key at this point if
you really stop and think she's kind of
the key of the whole thing because she's
the only one that truly will support
whiterose blindly at this at this
juncture mr. robot is going to want to
continue to destroy ich orb Angela's
gonna want to continue to destroy ich
orb
Elliot should theoretically want to
destroy a Corp although whiterose may
have superseded them on his list so yeah
it's a pretty interesting place to be
after mid-season I think I think it
worked pretty well coming off the crazy
episode 5 and I'm excited to see what
happens
please like the video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already make sure you turn on
your notifications so that you'll know
and I not upload new mr. robot videos
I'm gonna try to get some extra bonus
videos in this week didn't really have
time for it last week so make sure you
follow along on my Twitter account and
you can follow me on Facebook and
Instagram too if you'd like thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon